taliban has appointed several hardline
members to afghanistan's caretaker
government among those appointed to the
new interim cabinet as senior minister
is siri jiddin haqqani who is on the
fbi's most wanted list
with us this former uk ambassador to
afghanistan sir nick k hello to nick
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning does this mean that
terrorists are in charge of afghanistan
um
indeed i think
half of the individuals out of the 30
named yesterday are on un sanctions
lists
and
indeed the haqqani network is a
prescribed terrorist organization in the
united states and in many countries uh
and the
leader of the haqqani group is now the
minister of interior uh so
um
yeah i mean i think this is a
phenomenally
uh
silly thing for the for the taliban to
do it's a strategic mistake uh they had
the chance to set up a a
reasonably inclusive government to bring
in other other figures other parties
other ethnic groups and they have failed
to do that i think it's a flaw in their
makeup they are single-minded
uncompromising and it's probably a sign
of weakness as well because they have
internal divisions they've had to
satisfy all their internal groups by
appointing them to to different jobs
strategic mistake or deliberate decision
it's a deliberate decision but as i say
i think it may sow the seeds eventually
uh for for failure because nobody can
govern sustainably afghanistan unless
the government reflects the diversity of
the country when people look at the
government they want to see themselves
reflected and now
30 uh people have been appointed who are
from the pashtun ethnic group and only
three are non-pashtuns that immediately
is a non-inclusive government
where does that leave western
democracies trying to deal with
afghanistan
yeah it makes it makes it harder that's
why i say it's a real you know it's a
mistake by the taliban they you know if
they had been able to present a
reasonably credibly inclusive face to
the world i think they would have found
the reception much easier but now
governments will find it very hard
indeed in some cases legally impossible
to engage with this government that
doesn't mean that we should be isolating
them and i certainly firmly believe that
at working level not a full
ambassadorial level we should have a
presence there why because we need eyes
and ears on the ground to see what's
happening at the moment we rely on the
very good reporting from the
international media who are the glare of
media publicity i think is
curbing a little bit some of the taliban
excesses in kabul uh but it shouldn't be
just the media i think we need eyes and
ears or diplomats as well yeah they say
the government is not uh tribal this is
the taliban quoting this taliban this
morning um and it will represent all
afghanis
except women it would appear at this
stage
there are no women in those top
government appointments whatsoever at
all
and it is women that you can see now
every day on the streets of kabul and
other cities herat as well protesting
against the taliban incredibly brave uh
women
and i think you know what this is a sign
as afghanistan really has changed
taliban may not have changed haven't
changed
afghanistan has this is now facebook
generation everybody is linked in on
smartphones etc not just within
afghanistan people know what's going on
but in across the world as well and
taliban are going to have to adapt to
that new reality if they want to sustain
their power
we've also been hearing from ngos on the
ground in afghanistan and they're
telling us that basic services are not
working as they should that food is
running eight uh running out i should
say in 18 million people are desperately
in need of aid one wonders how it could
deteriorate so quickly and how much
blame the west really does need to
accept for what's happening in
afghanistan today
um i think there's plenty of blame to go
around for everyone the humanitarian
situation was pretty bad before
the the taliban offensive combination of
climate change that's affected you know
climate patterns so drought and floods
in some some places
the conflict for 20 years has it
definitely you know limited the economy
limited agricultural production as well
so
combination of things means that the
country is facing enormous humanitarian
challenges and i very much welcome the
fact that the un relief chief was in
kabul two days ago to start
conversations about how the
international community can provide aid
to keep afghans alive and that i think
is really important we need to sort of
differentiate that aid for humanitarian
purposes from any aid to help improve
the country over the long term that
development aid i think is not on the
agenda for now particularly
with the government that has been
appointed yesterday
but humanitarian aid shouldn't be
politicized and we should work through
the u.n with that
we need to keep an eye on what's going
on with other nations as well don't we
china just speaking to the reuters news
agency a foreign office ministry
spokesperson for the chinese saying
we're ready to maintain communication
with the new afghan government and
leader they're keen to fill that vacuum
that's been left
china has a border as we know with
afghanistan they have
a long-term interest in what happens in
afghanistan because of the repercussions
potentially upon its muslim
population in china um
so yes they will you know they will
continue to play an interest i read the
chinese responses relatively muted in a
way that i haven't seen china or
pakistan or any other countries really
rushing into a very very fulsome welcome
or embrace of this this new government
and uh you know i think it will give
everyone a pause for thought this is not
the inclusive government that i believe
even pakistan for example was was
calling for
uh so yeah we do need to do to watch
that
yeah so nick um obviously the war in
afghanistan started 20 years ago in
october of 2001 as a result of what
happened on 9 11. do you remember where
you were when you heard the news
for 9 11 yes i remember i was working in
the foreign office here in london in the
policy planning staff
and
it was certainly a very dramatic moment
for
for the whole world obviously for the
tragedy but you know for people working
on foreign policy it was a moment at
which we went into overdrive in terms of
you know what on earth does this mean
and how is it going to impact on
everything we do
very quickly it became obvious that you
know nothing was going to be the same uh
post 9 11 and indeed the last 20 years
we can see that
you